- So I have to ask, what was
the last day on set like?
Cause it, that's a big deal.
- Yeah, it was awful, it was awful.
- [Rachel] It was terrible.
- A lot of tears.
- It was painful.
I mean, we just all, we
love the show so much.
We love the work.
And we just couldn't quite
wrap our brains around the fact
that it was coming to a close.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Rachel] Alex and I.
- I feel like sometimes it
doesn't hit you til afterward.
- Yeah, we had been.
I mean, Alex is a picture of
stoicism most days on set.
(chuckling)
- Yeah, I'm usually very
cold, and well, kinda mean.
(laughing)
- I saw the other word
flash through your eyes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You said mean for Kelly Clarkson.
- She kept it daytime.
- Yeah, daytime, it's day time.
- Don't worry, they have
to bleep me all the time.
You're fine.
- But we, we had to
rehearse one of our scenes
early that morning on the last day.
And we came in and just sort
of stood across from each other
and we were starting to rehearse.
And Alex was getting teary at
like 8 o'clock in the morning.
- I couldn't look at her.
I just went like.
- Could not look me
in the eyes.
And then I couldn't look her in the eyes.
And so we spent all of
our rehearsals, kind of,
I think I was looking at
the center of your forehead
and you were looking at my--
- But, to be fair, isn't that usually
where you have to look at me?
- You're right, yep. (laughing)